I would love to be at the wedding to see
them because I think they're so happy I
know they're so happy
but again that's conjecture and I would
think they would go for the younger
performer
looks like Elton John will have the
honor of performing at the Royal Wedding
after all and the musician may have some
surprises in store for Prince Harry and
Megan markle's big day a source tells ET
Elton plans to sing at the couple's
reception after they say I do at Windsor
Castle well this comes as no surprise as
the musician has a special connection to
the royal family as one of Princess
Diana's closest confidants she had this
incredible ability which he's kind of
inherited and I told him that he would
thanks very much to make people feel at
ease and make them feel that
everything's gonna be alright we're told
it's likely that Elton will honor
Harry's mother Diana with a tribute on
Saturday our ET source adds one in which
Elton will speak at the wedding and say
how much she is missed on this very
special day I'm sure to be over the moon
jumping up and down I was so excited for
it for me but then as I said would have
probably been best friends best friends
I'm Megan so no it's
I you know days like today when I really
miss having her around though Diana's
presence will be sorely missed on
Harry's big day his grandfather won't
miss the royal wedding Buckingham Palace
confirms to ET Prince Phillip will be
attending the ceremony just six weeks
after he underwent hip replacement
surgery
you
[Music]